hi my name is sarah and i
live in phoenix arizona and i'm
wondering if
you're willing to discuss just something
interesting that i've noticed so i'm in
my first year of sobriety after a long
struggle with drugs and alcohol i
am a long time athlete playing lots of
sports and loving running
and i was wondering if you were willing
to discuss
how overcoming substance abuse
has changed your mindset on
fitness your life your goals
your athleticism just things like that
i'm a huge fan
of the show and i'm super happy to even
reach out but hopefully you'll
address these kinds of things in the
talk because your story is really
powerful and i think it would empower a
lot of other people
to take hold of their life their bodies
their fitness
thanks again and i hope that you all are
having a wonderful day
cool thanks for the question sarah
um congrats on a year of sobriety that's
a huge deal
amazing um and it's a great question
it's an interesting question i mean the
first thing i would say
is sobriety first
like don't be confused like there is
a confused narrative out there that
uh that somehow like being vegan or
being an athlete
contributed to me getting sober and
staying sober and that's
just not what happened at all like i
didn't get and stay sober because i went
vegan or
became an endurance athlete i got and
stayed sober
by overcoming denial finding people to
talk to
being honest holding myself accountable
working a program
in the secret rooms and and helping
others and working with a sponsor
and doing an inventory and making amends
and it's really only when
i created a solid foundation of sobriety
that i began to
expand in other areas like being vegan
and becoming this middle
aged endurance athlete came many years
after i got sober at 31
i didn't start doing ultras until i was
42. i got
i got you know i went vegan at 40. so
there's a decade
after getting sober where i was trying
to sort my [ __ ] out
and get my life back on track before any
of these other things so this idea this
notion that
your addictive personality can just go
from one thing to then you can put an
athlete he could put a make him an
athlete instead and he can channel and
that that confidence i mean
you could it's just that's not how it
played out for me like i had a decade of
of you know being a workaholic and like
eating shitty food
i transferred many addictive tendencies
onto other things that weren't drugs or
alcohol
and i it took me a long time in my
spiritual evolution to like grapple with
those things and
as they say the road gets narrower like
when you first get sober
just to not drink is everything right
anything else is fine it's just like
just don't drink right and then the more
emotionally sober you get the less
tolerant you become
of other behaviors and proclivities that
you have that used to not bother you
like
you just can't get away with it anymore
because the more emotionally sober and
mature you become you realize that those
things are at odds with you being
the most you know actualized person that
you can be so whether it's
you know going to gamble or
shopping too much or working whatever
you know shitty self-care habits
whatever it is like
those things become if you get sober
enough they become unbearable and they
have to go
as well and this is a it's called slow
brighty it takes a long time
so in my case these things didn't happen
in lockstep
and so i just want to impress upon
anybody who's listening to understand
that
things like you know running cycling
just you know self-care
physical fitness diet sleep meditation
these things are all beneficial to
sobriety and meditation is actually a
core aspect of sobriety but none of them
can take the place of of working a
program
and i know there's various different
ways of getting sober and staying sober
but
you know i got sober in 12 step and that
got me sober it's kept me sober it's
still
the most important thing in my life i
tried all these other ways they didn't
work
this is just work what works for me but
i will say
in more specific response to your
question that
getting sober led to
performing more esteemable acts on
behalf of myself and behalf of other
people and esteemable acts in turn
lead to elevated self-esteem which in
turn
expands your horizon of what's possible
for yourself in other words you begin to
believe in yourself you begin to believe
that you can do more and you can be more
and that means that you end up taking on
things
that you never would have previously you
get more interested in bettering
yourself and in
improving the quality of life of those
around you
and challenges that once might have
seemed impossible
you end up welcoming and in my case that
took the form of these endurance
challenges and
later writing books starting this
podcast for you it's going to be
different of course but these are all
practices that contribute and reinforce
my sobriety but
they're not um they're not
interchangeable with the program itself
running specifically i think is
interesting
i think swimming is the same way as this
practice of active meditation
it's something that's very honest and
and keeps you honest
it doesn't care who you think you are
who you tell yourself you are who you
tell
other people you know who you are
because it tells you who you are and
and that makes it this this amazing and
beautiful template for
for self-discovery and self-improvement
and just it's just one of the reasons
why i love
endurance sports and that's all great
just don't replace
a program uh your program for
for running as a solution
[Music]
you